let's go down the rabbit hole of this
enterprise Bach chain or you know not
Bitcoin but blockchain I said to agree
with you that 99 percent of those use
cases or applications or complete
garbage right and you know if you take a
step back and you remove all of the hype
and sexiness of the word blockchain
you're talking about a database right I
mean that is what we're talking about
exactly and so in order for people to
get that excited about a database there
would either have to be one some you
know such a technical leap in terms of
efficiency effectiveness etc or two
there would have to be something that
that you know database allowed us to do
that we previously weren't able to do
before yeah it's a it's a sort of
enterprise block chains or back office
automation system right it's a form of
like back it's a back office upgrade
essentially and the awesome part is Wall
Street historically doesn't put money
into the back office right puts the bare
minimum because it's not a profit Center
it's a cost center you know why invest
more in the back office than you
absolutely need to this really is a way
for back-office
teams to lobby for more financing for
their for the sort of essential
infrastructure that needs to upgrade and
so I don't see a lot of value being
captured there you know because actually
they're creating hypothetically more
efficient systems you have to if there's
all these sort of improved efficiencies
a lot I don't I don't see how it might
be cutting costs but I don't see it
creating and subsequently capturing a
lot of value which is you know the
disconnect I think a lot of people have
in this ecosystem broadly not just on
Wall Street but in general is the
disconnect between value creation and
value capture I I think that that
problem remains largely you know
unsolved and in many teams Minds
absolutely and so if Bitcoin is the
digital currency right and maybe take
some time to play out but but we
eventually get to hey this is a true
currency that has multiple properties
that we're looking for do you think that
there is a world in the
digital age of Finance where there is
digital stocks digital bonds digital
commodities kind of all of these other
applications that aren't necessarily
Enterprise blockchain but they are
digital assets they're native to this
environment but they represent or have
analogous you know kind of properties to
their non digital peers
yes bomb I I think will tokenize the
world now the I I think that all sort of
financial instruments will eventually be
digital in some form right even even
stuff that's represented with paper now
in in the basement of the DCC I think
it's all going to be digital it's sort
of inevitable and I you know sort of
welcome that future that'll be really
exciting I think that there will emerge
kind of new capital market structures
altogether where deals will be financed
sort of frictionlessly all over the
world you know you'll be able to move
from broker jada brokerage be in a very
straightforward process I think that all
that infrastructure will eventually
exist because they see you know capital
markets and capital formation
I see sort of sound money first as the
largest addressable market and and not
by you know small differences by many
orders of magnitude and then sort of
second thing I find compelling is
actually a recreation of a capital
market structure around that so I do
think that this will be somewhat
inevitable but actually the things that
are interesting to me here or less
around what a lot of you know it's sort
of more tokenized securities offerings
and kind of unique financing models and
on people have proposed you know doing
under reg D offerings here in the u.s.
what I'm interested in is actually kind
of like the more subversive stuff right
where I would consider by Nantz finance
going right B&B finances Native exchange
token to be an example of what I would
consider a subversive you know illegal
securities offering is a stretch because
it might be illegal only the US
investors but you know they basically
raised an ICO
the issued a token in exchange for that
had some discounts and features for
holders of the token and then issued up
basically burn mechanism where they
bought back tokens and subsequently
burned them based on their profits every
quarter and now they're launching you
know very very very sizable crypto fund
that's investing in very high quality
early stage projects and they're
basically passing on returns from that
fund back to users right so you know
what I'm describing is entirely a
security right it's a very sort of
unique form of security where it has
this dual utility function and security
like feature where you know the benefits
of the efforts of finance and and their
team feeds right back into the security
and many people would be appalled right
they would consider it super illegal but
what they've now created is a very broad
investor base of you know tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of investors all over the world all of
whom have profited substantially that
Hogan has appreciated substantially and
they've been fully transparent I think
the next levels for them is moving to a
decentralized exchange model which
they've been working on for some time
first second you know shifting to a
model where all of their cash flows are
actually directly distributed on chain
right and they can do you know once they
have a decentralized exchange going they
can even do potential buybacks and and
burning functions all autonomously and
you know what happens in that universe
starts to resemble something much more
close to a dowel structure and while I
think the Dow was a disaster it was
still exciting right it was exciting for
me to follow it's still exciting to me
now I think the potential word aus is
very underappreciated and all these days
I think will have you know equity like
characteristics right I think that that
will exist all over the world and all
sorts of different capital formation
structures and that's really cool to me
and and so around that I do see a whole
new sort of decentralized financial
system forming whether all of these will
have separate tokens I don't know
whether but and there's a number of
questions that remains that are how
look in this sort of a dowel like
universe but it's cool it's exciting